number 21 is Robertson back to suder shoots it
and a right P save by hoper and he's into the
game early and that's flopped High by Breo near
the Dallas line and now the veteran pavelski on
for Robertson had 46 goals last year shoots it on
goal against Chicago here's pero round back now
to corenko and then for Hayes trying to Center
one actually play it off the armor back of the
go tender and now the blue is Into The Zone Kyu
what a pass for Thomas and then back for Kyu at
the line brunovich fires it right on goal and
a save by Wedgewood and that's kept a lot and
now it's Kyu again for Thomas this line buzzing
early brunovich low throws it low in front now
Davis bangs away and now Essa Lindell for the
Stars shot 32 for the blues as hoer plays that
one around Ben on it shoots it and a sck save by
Hofer that's rope a hints after him can't catch
it what a pass brunovich drops it and a drrive
right on goal by Kyu and a save by Wedgewood
and the stars come back Leep pass to Harley and he
comes in and caught from behind and now Robertson
deals it back to Harley K trying to pinch and
then sunquist runs out of real estate the stars
come back in and now Ben in front trying to get
turned around drops it and a shot wide by gono
through a screen and now snared by MCC and his
pass ahead for Faulk who's jumping early in this
game and he throws it in deep penpa had trouble
with it against Shen but now works it ahead and
Sam steel and this goes deep hoer around well
prco just blew a tire of the corner the blues
get it back in casber Ka and theend to Center ice
that's off the pad of Wedgewood that's kept in by
hkin and pass across Sean shoots it and a save
by Hofer now it's comes in front again Marchman
in the area will get it back and here they come to
Center and that goes deep hul there fights off the
gon off check and now Ben back of the goal stole
it in front and a great save by Hur on Johnston
right in front his best save on the second ing
pass to Johnston after Ben stole the pock and
now Ben again fires it and a save by hord he has
been sharp early coach to their wi like that and
uh of course he could be his toughest critic if
she wants as the stars come in it's centered H
for spinning around and it stays out and now H
get in with it to the goal crease area right in
front foxa dropped another shot by Suter and that
was walked in the slot and the blues finally get
it back and here they come and Brandon saw it at
the line Paro wide open right in a shot and a save
by Wedgewood now Robertson at Center here's hints
again he'll drop it off for pavelski to bend right
in a shot and a save by Hofer back for hin in and
then for hint seam pass Robertson hin in lets it
Go hord got over made a great save on B on that
play but it all starts back here Joel huler look
at that save not fighting at all holding their
ground taking away some of those passing lanes
and ultimately they do and they end up killing off
another power play against the Dallas Stars they
know Hawken clock back of the goal lost the puck
though good for check by saw flip back now for
perunovic he walks the line neighbor shs he scores
neighbors and the blows have drawn first BL at one
nothing denying Jamie Ben and watch got brunovich
blocks the line draws that coverage and then Jake
neighbors with the shot but you can't Overlook
the traffic in front of the net it's a great
shot but Brandon final minute of the first perck
now San for duain at the line Suter shot right
on goal rebound loose there and the Blues With It
Breco ahead and Kapp in under some pressure from
Marchman and then CPP is a good job to shovel the
puck in with 35 left in the opening period and now
Meo hkin in their first round pick in 2017 here
comes the donov down the wall pass in front that's
Swept Away by through and then Kyo stars with
it in front and a glove save kyou now for Thomas
Thomas to B davic looks to center it now B davage
for Ley quick shot on goal save by Wedgewood and
recovered by the blues and now Kyu darts out hot
now kyou trying to slide one through for Thomas
that was blocked and the Stars had the other way
hint to Robertson to hin and right in a shot and a
glove save by hord it's Justin fall for the blues
now to the goal scor neighbors neighbors through
the middle now to Capp in for Shen he comes Cent
a shot and a glove save by Scott Wedgewood couple
of Blues around him including Turk Jacob scandal
at the liner shot tipped on the way through and
a save that was a tough one on Wedgewood going to
deal around Suter Cen needs it back for f shoots
it big rebound off Wedgewood in front and now grab
played back to the line for Tory K he gets set
up again and Thomas across toin shoots it on goal
rebound B loose there b davage for maros scandella
tipped across now to neighbors and then scandella
back for prun waiting on the outside now scandella
up the middle shoots he scores scandel with a
neigher screen and the blues take a two nothing
lead rotating Scott perunovic who's having
himself a great game he keeps the puckle and
then maros gandel Loops back down middle of the
ice fires that with Jake neighbors right in front
not sure if Jake got a piece of that or not but
he certainly took away the eyeballs of Wedgewood
and marus scandel ripped that from cidan and
perunovich now the stars in Smith a shot and
a save by hoper off his arm now in front again
another chance yeah that will help the blues get
a quick change get some fresh bodies on the ice
now the STS come back in Sheen going wide and a
shot and a save by hord try to slide it bit on
that one as he's looking One Direction and then
he slides the puck back the other way but Joel
hulur now back to kyrus tipped Here Comes Shen
Thomas in front backhander and a save by Wedgewood
and the rebound is fired down by Steel 45 to go in
the five on three now to crew shoots it rebound
Shen and he can't knock it in it's still loose Lo
now bu davit to kyou and Wedgewood somehow kept it
out and it's still loose Smith back to the blues
with eight shots on that five on three and can't
score here comes faul to the line Loston stars get
it Robertson in waiting and he scores and is that
a big goal for Dallas and Robertson makes it two
to one to penetrate and score a goal and then you
got Tire Tory Krug here trying to get to the bench
a turnover there and unfortunately they head back
the other way and Robinson Zips this one to the
blocker side now pelski trying to walk around
crew in a couple of players back of the gold
traffic jam there comes fre lindella drive and
it's saved by hord and now Johnston back of the
goal at the line hawen paaw now to Lindell lets it
go and that goes wide on the short side ful comes
over but hawen pop pinches and then Lindell with
it for the stars comes all the way around hawen
po again shoots it on goal save Hofer Haw loose
in the slot Stars playing around kick by budavich
to Shen and that's wide it doesn't matter as the
blues will hang on and win two to one is the final